افادم راس العربي ان ثماني سفن متوقفه في
قناه السويس ناقله النفط المتعطله هو
اعلنت هيئه قناه السويس المصريه دفع ثلاث
قاطرات لسحب ناقله نفط تعطلت محركاتها في
المجرى الملاحي وقال رئيس الهيئه اسامه
ربيع ان حركه قافله الشمال ستعود الى
طبيعتها عقب سحب ناقله النفط التي كانت في
طريقها من روسيا الى الصين ناقله الان يتم
سحبها طبقا للصور التي رايناها صور تتبع
السفن لانها كانت في واحده من قطاعات
القناه الشماليه التي ليس بها ازدواج ويتم
سحبها لمنطقه من الممكن ان تتوقف فيها
للاصلاح لكي تستانف مره اخرى حركه العبور
رئيس هيئه قناه السويس منذ اقل من ساعه
كان قد تحدث الى احد البرامج التلفزيونيه
المحليه وذكر فيها انه في تقديره ان هناك
يعني ساعه من العمل
تستانف بعدها الحركه فنحن ربما ننتظر في
ايه لحظه ان يصلنا ان يصل لنا هذا الخبر
الصور اظهرت تحرك السفينه من موقع الى
موقع
ويبدو ان من الصور اذا كنت قد قراتها بشكل
صحيح انه يتم الان صفها او ايقافها في
منطقه يسمح فيها بالاصلاح دون ان يكون
هناك اي تعكير حركه الملاحه في القناه
القافله قافله الشمال المتجهه جنوبا كانت
تضم تسعه عشر سفينه ترتيب السيفيجر محل
الخبر كان ترتيبها الحادي عشر او الحادي
عشر كنقله نفط
وتتوقفت الحركه من بعدها لثماني سفن اخرى
منها نقلتان للنفط فسيجر ليست من السفن
القديمه هي سفينه تعتبر حديثه
عام 2016 هذا يعني قصير في عمر السفن
بطبيعه الحال كما نعلم السفينه ترفع علم
مالطا طولها 275 متر تقريبا وعرضها يكاد
يقترب من الخمسين متر حاليا عمليه الرباط
كما يطلق عليها اهل الملاحه في قناه
السويس تعتمد على ايصال كابلات من القطرات
لكي يتم سحب السفينه المتعطله هذا حدث
يعني
وهذه الحادثه حدثت من قبل وتحدث مساله
تعطل السفن خلال العبور وهناك نوع من
البروتوكول تتعامل بهيئه قناه السويس
اساسه بطبيعه الحال وجود مرشد لكل تابع
لهيئه قناه السويس يعتلي
ظهر السفينه قبل الابحار في المجرى
الملاحيه واي اصحاب السفينه حتى نهايه
المجرى الملاحيه وخروجها سواء من جهه
الجنوب او جهه الشمال وبالتالي اسلوب
الابلاغ عن الاع طال المتطور جدا وايضا
يتم التعامل معه على الفور من المتوقع ان
يكون هذا التعطل مؤقت بصوره كبيره وكذلك
بالنسبه لقافله الجنوب سيتم ايقافها قليلا
في منطقه البحيرات هي تتجه من السويس شمال
سيتم الانتهاء من هذه الحادثه او يتم دفع
السفينه الى خارج
المتابعه دائمه شكرا لكم من القاهره على
كل هذه المعلومات وتفاصيل كنت معنا تامر
نشاط مراسله العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات